let f be a real valued function defined
on the interval from zero to infinity it
does not include zero and f is defined
as the natural log of x plus the
definite integral from zero to x of the
square root of one plus sine of t d of t
then which of the following statements
are true and so more than one of these
might be true so let's figure them out
so a says the second derivative there's
two there's two apostrophes here the
second derivative of f exists for all x
between
zero or really all x greater than 0.
then they say the first derivative
exists for all x greater than 0 and the
derivative is continuous on that
interval but not differentiable okay so
everything they're doing they're
relating the function to the first
derivative and the second derivative so
let's just figure those things out so
let's just write the function first
i'll just rewrite it here
the function f is equal to the natural
log of x plus the definite integral from
0 to x
of the square root of 1 plus sine
of t
dt
the derivative the derivative of f
so let me write it let me write it over
here
so f prime
of x is going to be equal to the
derivative of this first term derivative
of natural log of x is
1 over x and then derivative of this
that's just the fundamental theorem of
calculus is going to be just this inside
expression with respect to x as a
function of x so plus
the square root of one plus
one plus sine of x and now let's get the
third
let's or let's get the second derivative
now the second derivative i'll do it
over here f prime prime of x is going to
be equal to the derivative of this term
this is x to the negative 1. so it's
going to be negative x to the negative 2
or negative 1 over x squared that's
negative
x to the negative 2. you could view it
that way and then plus so let's do the
chain rule what's the derivative of the
inside derivative 1 plus sine of x is
cosine of x so plus
cosine of x
times that's 1 plus sine of x to the
one-half so it's going to be times
one-half times one plus sine of x
to the negative one-half so i took the
derivatives now let's look at the
choices so the first choice says the
second derivative of the function exists
for all x greater than zero if you're
going between zero and infinity and not
including zero that's essentially for
all x greater than zero let's see if
that is true
so over here the one area so this would
be undefined if x is equal to zero but
that's not in the interval over here now
let's see if there's so let's just be
clear when you take something to the
negative one-half power let me let me
rewrite it like this i could rewrite it
as
instead of writing to the negative
one-half power i can write it in the
denominator as the square root of 1 plus
sine of x so if this denominator becomes
undefined the second derivative won't be
undefined so let's think about when that
denominator might be undefined so it'll
be undefined if it equals zero so one
plus sine of x
is equal to zero well it's going to be
equal to zero if sine of x is equal to
negative one
if sine of x is equal to negative one
and sine of x can equal negative one at
x is equal to let's see if you go around
the unit circle sine
is the y coordinate so it has to go
around you could either go down it would
be negative 90 degrees or positive
270 degrees or if in radians if x is
equal to because we're assuming or at
least i'm assuming that we're dealing in
radians here if x is equal to 3 pi
if x is equal to 3 pi over 2 assuming
we're in radians that will make this
undefined
so
this f prime prime f prime prime not
defined
not defined at
x is equal to 3 pi over 2
which is clearly in this interval so
choice a is false choice a does not work
now let's see choice b says f prime of x
exists for all x's greater than 0. well
that seems to be the case you can't put
x equals 0 but that's not in the
interval
and f prime is continuous on 0 to
infinity yeah it's in continuous no
obvious discontinuities here but not
differentiable on 0 to infinity well
it's clearly not differentiable 0 to
infinity the derivative does not exist
when x is the derivative of the first
derivative or the second derivative does
not exist
at x is equal to 3 pi over 2. we just
saw that f prime of x is not
differentiable at 3 pi over 2. so
everything in this is true everything is
true it's not differentiable there
because the second derivative is not
defined at 3 pi over 2. let's do part c
now
part c there exists an alpha greater
than one such that f prime the the
magnitude the absolute value of f prime
of x is less than the absolute value of
f of x for all x
essentially greater than for all x
greater than that alpha so let's think
about this let's think about this a
little bit what we want to show is that
beyond some threshold beyond some
threshold the derivative is always going
to be smaller than the original f of x
or this is the derivative will always be
smaller than f of x so the first thing
we might want to see so let's just
compare the parts that are comparable so
let's compare first of all the natural
log of x let's compare the natural log
of x to 1 over x
so when is
let's just set a threshold here so is
there a number is there a number so b
at any number larger than that the
natural log of x is always going to be
larger than 1 over x and the number that
pops into my head just because it's an
easy number to work with with natural
log with natural logs is e
if so for x
for x is greater than e it's pretty
clear that the natural log of x is going
to be greater than 1 over x think about
it at e it's going to be evaluate to the
natural log of e which is 1 and 1 is
clearly greater than 1 over e right e is
2.71 so on and so forth so this is
clearly true and then as you get beyond
e as you get numbers larger than he is
this becomes e plus something this
number will become larger and then this
number over here will become smaller
because we'll be dividing by a larger
number so it's clear that it exists just
for this part for the first part the
natural log of x
beyond e and we just have to find some
threshold that might not be the first
threshold but the natural log of x is
definitely greater than one of f greater
than one over x when x is greater than e
now let's see if we can find a threshold
for the second part and if we can
then we can literally just pick the
larger of the two thresholds and then
that will be a threshold above which f
of x will always be larger than f prime
of x
and to think about it we just have to
see that essentially this part of the
function
this part of the function let me write
it this way let me write it this way
if i define this
if i define this as h of x
this is h of x this right here is h
prime of x
h prime of x we've already shown we've
already shown that for x is greater than
e
h of x is greater than
h prime
of x we've seen that already now let me
define this over here
let me define that as g of x
let me call that g of x and then this is
its derivative this is g prime of x
that is
g
prime of x
now this is let's just draw g of x let
me draw g of x or let me actually let me
draw g prime of x right over here
let me draw it it's actually a pretty
straightforward graph to draw
so let me draw it over here so when x is
equal to 0 sine of 0 is 0 plus 1 you
take the square root so 0
1 that's the first point
that is f of x equal to 1 when x is
equal to 0.
and then the next interesting point
maybe we'll take x is equal to pi over
2.
so when x is pi over 2 sine of pi over 2
is 1 1 plus 1 is 2 take the square root
so it's going to be the square root of 2
which is someplace around here
so the square root of 2 and then let's
just take when sine
when x is pi
sine of pi is 0 this becomes the square
root of 1 again so we're back over here
then let's go to 3 pi over 2
sine of 3 pi over 2 is negative 1
negative 1 plus 1 is going to be zero so
we're going to be down here and then we
go again to 2 pi
to 2 pi sine of 2 pi is 0 0
0 plus 1 is 1 take the square root
you're back over here so this graph
g prime of x we're calling it
this graph over here looks like this
this it looks something like this this
is my best attempt at drawing it
it just keeps oscillating at its maximum
point is square to two its minimum point
is zero and it keeps oscillating so this
is g prime of x
g prime of x is equal to the square root
of 1 plus sine of x now what is g of x
what is this thing over here well this
is the definite integral from 0 to x of
this thing so you take any x value you
take any x value
this thing over here g of x is the area
it's the area
over here so what's happening here so
let's let's think about this
as we get to larger and larger x values
the area gets bigger because this line
never drops below the x axis so as we
get larger and larger x values this area
just keeps getting bigger and bigger and
bigger so we can write g of x
g of x unbounded
unbounded
as
x
as x
goes to infinity g of x approaches
infinity what about g prime of x
g prime of x it maxes out it just keeps
oscillating between 0 and square root of
2. so g prime of x max or maybe i should
write it this way the max
of g prime of x is equal to the square
root of 2. so it's pretty clear that at
some point this area is going to be
there's some x value where this area is
going to be more than the square root of
2. let's call that point alpha and after
that alpha where you know maybe it's
over here i mean clearly we could say at
x equals 10 at x equals 10 we definitely
have a lot of area under this curve we
definitely have the area is definitely
bigger than the square root of 2. so let
me just write it there because we just
need to find some boundary so let's just
say
let's just say
at x greater than i'm just picking an
arbitrary number at x greater than 10 it
is clear
it's clear that
it's clear that the integral from 0 to x
of the square root of 1 plus sine of x
d or as you see one plus sine of that
one plus sine of t dt it's clear that
that is going to be greater than the
square root of one plus sine of x
because this is the area
at 10 this thing
at any value above 10 this thing at most
can ever get to square root of 2. this
thing is just going to keep growing and
growing and at 10 it's already going to
be larger than the square root of 2. so
we know that there's some boundaries so
for x is greater than 10
so let's write it this place
so 4
x greater than 10
well x 10 is definitely greater than e
we know that h of x
is greater than h prime of x we know
that's true 10 is clearly greater than e
so we can state that and we also know
that g of x we also know that g of x
is greater than g prime of x
so we know that f of x
which is equal to h of x plus g of x
is going to be greater than
is going to be greater than f prime of x
which was the derivative the sum of the
derivatives which is equal to h prime of
x plus g prime of x
so we know
we know that this is true we can make
alpha equal 10 and this thing is going
to be true so this is true
now let's do part d
there exists a beta greater than 0 such
that the absolute value of f of x plus
the absolute value
of the derivative of f is going to be
less than or equal to beta for all x
well we already know that f of x is
unbounded f of x is unbounded because
this part of it
this integral part of it right here just
keeps increasing as x gets larger and
larger and larger it never dips below we
never have negative area so the na so
this area just keeps growing so this is
unbounded and actually so is so is the
natural log of x the natural log of x is
also going to be unbounded so you cannot
say that it's going to be less than some
value because it can it's going to
approach infinity so it's not going to
be less than some value for all x
greater than for for for all x from 0 to
infinity so you can't bound it this is
an unbounded function just this part
just this part alone is an unbounded
function f prime of x is f prime of x
well even there you have to be careful
but f of x is clearly unbounded so this
can't be true there's not any kind of
roof you can put on the on on the as as
x if you said it was if you said
well i think you get the general idea so
this is definitely not true so the
answer here is b
and c